this video is sponsored by brilliant
pavel Matuszak is a scientist at the
Rutherford Appleton lab in the UK his
research has led to something that can
be called Superman vision and in the
next few years might change the way that
you fly well not not like that if you've
flown on a plane in the past few years
then you know that you're not allowed to
bring any liquid container greater than
100 millilitres in volume in your hand
luggage the reason that we're not
allowed to do so is of course to prevent
liquid bombs and similar threats to the
safety of the plane so for the hundred
milliliter restriction to be lifted
airport security would need to be able
to rapidly accurately screen liquids
without opening the containers therein
and this is actually now possible thanks
to a new technology developed by Pavel
and his colleagues it's already being
used in airports around the world to
screen large containers like baby milk
and medicine and it works using
something called spatially offset Raman
spectroscopy the Raman spectroscopy is a
technique which enables you to identify
the chemical composition of an object by
simply shining laser light onto it and
looking at the illuminated part or its
vicinity and looking at photons which
change colour so by shining a laser of a
known wavelength of light on a subject
you will get some light reflected back
with different wavelengths most of the
light will be elastically scattered or
Rayleigh scattered back meaning that it
will have the same wavelength as it did
when it left the laser but some of the
reflective light will have different
wavelengths this is known as inelastic
scattering coincidentally also what a
group of cats do when you surprise them
the idea of Raman spectroscopy is that
these changes in wavelength between the
incoming and reflected light are caused
by the molecules in the target substance
shifting energy levels in response to
laser light by energy level I mean the
rate at which the individual molecules
vibrate and rotate which is dependent on
what they're made of molecules are
raised from their initial ro vibronic
state incidentally an amazing word to a
virtual excited RO vibronic state when
they absorb a photon of laser light when
a molecule emits a photon which we
detect as the reflected light they
descend to another different state the
difference in energy between the initial
and final ro vibronic states is the same
as the difference in energy between the
incident
from the laser and the photon emitted by
the molecule because the energy of each
row vibronic state depends on the
structure of the molecule what it's made
of
the changes in wavelength of laser light
reflected off a material are specific to
that material the changes in wavelength
are like a fingerprint uniquely
identifying a particular substance if
you perform Raman spectroscopy on some
unknown sample you could identify what
it was made of by comparing its
fingerprints to a known database of
other substances this is how Raman
spectroscopy works normally if you were
to identify a powder or a friend that
you haven't seen in years something
without a container but in order for
scanning technology to be usable in
airports it's got to be able to see
through containers and that is Superman
vision ability to probe deep inside
these objects was advanced at this
facility in my research with my
colleagues where we learned that simply
by illuminating an object at one point
and collecting signals several
millimeters let's say one centimeter
away you can see better deeper lying
components or objects taking that second
measurement is key because the photons
of laser light don't just reflect off
the surface of the container they
migrate deeper into its contents
spreading downwards and away from the
laser the photon still interact with the
molecules of the containers contents
raising their row vibronic States and
making them emit photons with different
wavelengths when they jump back down
these emitted photons are also detected
at the surface but the signal from the
containers contents is very weak
compared to all the photons being
emitted by the container if you look at
the point illuminated by the laser and
that one would be blinded by the surface
signal and typically be blind to the
chemical signatures hidden in it from
subsurface layers or from the content
however if you take a second measurement
say a centimeter away then you pick up a
much weaker signal from the container
and so a relatively much stronger signal
from the contents of the container but
you still have two signals two
fingerprints overlapping one another one
from the container and one
its contents so you use the first
measurements to define a fingerprint for
the container and subtract that from the
second measurements to isolate the
fingerprint of the contents
the larger the spacial offset the
separation between illumination and
collection point the higher the
likelihood with photons penetrating
deeper so by varying this separation you
can control from which depth
statistically photons originate
therefore what's the signature they
convey whether this this is a surface of
a container or content so with this
technique you're able to see into a
container and within reason determine
what the contents are at an arbitrary
depth beneath the surface I've compared
it to Superman vision in this video
because I'm a massive nerd but Pavel has
another amazing and equally geeky
comparison the critically that also
tricorder but not you know with the same
capability but getting close to it
because we can also diagnose disease we
are using exactly the same technique to
diagnose the presence or absence of
breast cancer all presence of bone
disease non-invasively so if you've ever
wondered why big expensive research
facilities exist or how they benefit
your life just remember you may soon be
able to fly with more than hobbit-sized
supplies of toiletries and if you get
sick while traveling Star Trek level
technology held in the palm of your hand
yes this is an actual product developed
by Pavel spin-off company may help to
diagnose you and this is all possible
because of laser science this video only
briefly touched on the physics of laser
lights which is really the physics of
quantum mechanics if you'd like to learn
more about this fascinating subjects one
of my favorites from my degree then I'd
highly recommend the course on quantum
objects on brilliant org the course is
broken down into bite-size chunks
building up the weird mathematics of
quantum theory before teaching you the
actual mechanics in each lesson you'll
be taking on practice problems learning
from your mistakes before moving on to
the next topic this in my opinion is the
single best way to learn any topic and I
highly highly recommend brilliance
because it's what the whole website is
built on if you like the sound of
learning about the Khan
world with this technique then check out
the link in the description
brilliant dorg forward slash Simon Clark
and the first 200 people to do so will
get 20% off their premium annual
subscription thank you for watching the
video you may also enjoy the video I
made previously with the central laser
facility about the most recent Nobel
Prize in Physics thank you so much to
the central a/c facility for inviting me
out to make these videos I had a really
really great time and thanks especially
to Pavel for agreeing to me being
interviewed by me it was a really really
fun experience thank you to them and
thank you again for watching I'll see
you the next one